[Music]
and proven wrong news submitted by Cocoa
Puffs
a DNA study confirms the first known
female Viking warrior how do we know
it's a female DNA that doesn't mean [ __ ]
anymore because now if you identify it a
certain way that is what you are you
could identify it as a man okay why does
science hate this new thing that we're
all doing how come how come we know that
it's a woman if DNA
well she's genetically female we don't
know what she cares about that's all we
care about
oh so there is a genetical thing with
female and male that's witchcraft bro
right anyway so there was no known
female Vikings before this I didn't even
really realize that well there were
there were female what time I saw this
what time I saw this porno where does
this hot lady had a penis and then I was
peaking in the middle of it right where
she was getting sucked off by another
female right but I was thinking at this
moment should I be saying that's a
really hot clitoris right now or should
I be saying is that a penis how do you
feel about those parts like dan that
girl's hot but Dan so weird I don't know
how to feel but is that a woman a woman
no hey hear me out
no no I didn't know it was I didn't know
it was it was that kind of porno baby
baby baby you understand it was it was
it was two girls kissing I thought it
was lesbian it's in Transylvania I don't
know it's a vampire porn I don't know
yeah come on now yeah it was it was it
was lesbian baby I would never do that
to you they're making out and then one
girl goes down slowly thinking I thought
no I started laughing because I was like
whoa is this supposed to be a vagina
like am i she identifies as a woman so
is this a vagina now you're right she's
sucking on real hard vagina like like
that's what else
I thought of laughing in my head is this
Viking woman like Joan of Arc and [ __ ]
like she pretended to be a [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] okay so look man yeah some mad
[ __ ] move yeah okay so new discovery
here so initially the body was first
excavated in in the 1880s committee
where they escalated said a great hunter
under the bus men women helping women
hashtag women helping women you see we
just can't stop interrupting her you see
you you've been tell me you didn't you
stop interrupting tip at this point I'm
addicted to it honestly somebody call
the ambulance I start evacuating anyway
she was first excavated that was on us
we got you baited excavate Mexicans
don't pronounce the eggs as much okay so
anyway there was cute cute his body was
first that's taken out of them no say
the word you say the Lord with it I want
to go be perfect
okay evacuated talk about words what's
our heart
yeah words words words all right hash
browns own so they first initially
thought that this body was a male
because it was so bought no because it
was buried with two horses a lot of
weapons including a sword and armor
piercing arrows along with so women
couldn't war okay they assumed his
gender unbelievable these researchers
are so sexist [ __ ] sexist
anthropologist you need to be wallop
dude uh walk about it I know she was
also varied with game pieces so then
that's what pink girls don't definitely
a boy girls don't didn't didn't even
know how to do games no so the game
pieces symbolized that this is a high
level like leader like that this person
would actually plan out the battles in
wars their planner so they couldn't have
been a woman as well the researchers
were determining I feel like women are
way better planners and men absolutely
someone noticed that the bones were
really small like the hip bones are
really small so they were like you know
what I feel like this might be a female
so then they did a DNA collection of the
skeletons left canine and left humerus
and then they discovered that there were
two X chromosomes and no y chromosome
which means that this is a female that
doesn't mean that it's a female they can
get DNA off of bones that old I guess I
don't know anything about archaeology
yeah apparently Bill Nye told me that
the X chromosomes thing doesn't matter
and that it's just yeah that's how you
identify no but he said to me when I was
a kid it's pretty confusing because when
I was a kid he said that if you have an
X and Y chromosome that you're a male
and if you have two X chromosomes you're
a female but then he said that that's
not true he did bunk himself 20 years
later so I don't think he did Bill Nyes
no longer the Science Guy yeah no he's
just an sjw Guyana
my SJW guys the truth should ever fail
and I have the SJW guy so it was found
in Sweden here that's cool they're still
finding [ __ ] you know I feel like after
all these years no they found it 80
maybe so they decided to just now decide
they realize oh my god after hundreds of
years she might be old lady yeah that's
right I was mentioning that someone
noticed like hey I know that warrior has
boobs no but remember we went to the
museum and we saw the men the armor for
the men was tiny like they had told ya
something like how did they him has been
really small for the think of the French
saw okay well maybe the Vikings are
bigger that's for sure yeah they did
mention that this woman was 5/8 and so
that was really tall don't like it back
in the day that makes sense yeah so
these are the bones and they were first
found and these are the two horses and
then here's the female and then the Aldo
of the armor and stuff and then this is
a big draw drew it out to look like when
she was first buried so then that's why
I just made headlines everywhere cuz
there and here's a stock photo of a
Viking woman
they were same a big stock photo yet
they labeled it a target they found one
female Viking warrior
we found one female biking war you
finally have actual like DNA evidence of
a female that had all the this armor
blood now they could produce TV shows
that have female vet biking warriors to
to be historically accurate
boom Sokka yeah but I need that woman to
be really ugly though why cuz I'm trying
to sort yeah as historically accurate do
look at the president's wives back in
the day it gets [ __ ] nuts
the president's wives what like it's
like crazy dude it's like why like I'm
like are you sure they don't have
identify as dude
they're like the leader of the war like
Martha Washington yeah like you tell me
George Washington's not gay his wife
looks like Ulysses s granny she wrote a
very long and comprehensive blogpost
questioning the veracity of the
conclusions of this Viking female
warrior so she's saying that there's a
lot of things off about this that there
were no language specialists consulted
when they were looking into this they
were not sure if these are even the
correct bones that were in that grave
site they're not sure if she was a
high-ranking warrior that there were no
signs of harm and healing on the bone so
unlikely it's unlikely as she was a
fighter and then that there were no
other possible explanations pursued so
there's just a lot of holes in it maybe
she was the best [ __ ] fighter did you
say she's not a high she was undefeated
maybe they just brought her along it's
like a little concubine and while they
were fighting or something you know the
cumdumpster of this know but didn't they
bury
they buried her with horses she's really
seen you get offended I should I say you
[ __ ] called chick cumdumpster yeah a
high-ranking warrior did you call her
back um Dempster I think she could do it
because she's a lady I love it she said
other things for me I think what
happened was it was a grave site and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] slipped and fell in
there no I mean there's so many
speculations like what if there was a
man in there and then they were taken
out and then that was his concubine next
to him that's possible that's why
there's two horses I wonder if they like
offends the country to feel like oh
there wasn't women in our Viking are no
they're actually very respected in the
Viking culture women yeah women
don't they let women vote no they really
respected them though the [ __ ] out of
office yeah they were free to choose
their spouse and free to divorce I mean
in history there's even societies that
were like matriarchs yeah did the Queen
of England bud yeah Queen Victoria Queen
all the [ __ ] it's like come on I hope
you guys enjoyed this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]